eu queria passar uma mensagem para vocês
hoje aqui é bastante curta
eu sempre tive muita curiosidade sobre o
mundo desde criança eu já deixava minha
mãe louca desde pequeno eu subi no
telhado em dias de tempestade para ver
os raios mais de perto uma vez com os 11
anos de idade
eu decidi ir pescar com um vizinho de
bicicleta gente pegar uns quatro
quilômetros até uma lagoa sem avisar
ninguém e no final da tarde eu voltei
com o peixe vivo numa sacola plástica
pendurado no guidão da bicicleta
vim de casa em casa pelo caminho pedindo
água pra manter o peixe vivo que a
sacola estava furada e na volta pra casa
e levou um puxão de orelha da minha mãe
nenhum e um abraço apertado eu sempre
tive uma ligação muito forte com o mundo
natural passava noites em claro olhando
o céu
eu morava na cidade pequena tinha um céu
maravilhoso e eu viajava longe no meio
das estrelas aos 14 anos sabia o nome de
das 100 estrelas mais brilhantes do céu
isso de certa forma me me formou
eu me lembro de uma vez o meu pai chegou
pra mim e desfilou seu avô morreu
ele foi atropelado eu me lembro que no
minuto seguinte já estava de novo no
quintal olhando as estrelas
isso me dá uma perspectiva cósmica e me
colocava no meu devido lugar é
infinitamente pequeno mas também parte
de algo muito maior então eu cresci e
ganhei dinheiro comprei um carro comprei
um terno e desaprende um pouco a fazer
essas coisas e via aos poucos aquele
menino ficando distante
isso não fazia muito sentido para mim
aos 27 anos eu resolvi sair em busca
daquele menino e tirei um sonho antigo
da gaveta que era viajar de bicicleta
pela américa do sul
eu fui eu viajei 15 mil 500 quilômetros
aproximadamente por seis países em 365
dias
fui do atlântico ao pacífico dos pampas
ao atacama dos andes amazônia e bom esse
e só não teve um começo assim tão
simples
no segundo dia de viagem eu tive um
acidente e fraturei o punho esquerdo e
machuquei também bastante o meu
companheiro de viagem
nesse trecho os primeiros 15 dias
martinho ele teve a presença de espírito
de registrar esse momento é e não só
fisicamente e foi difícil é lógico que
eu tive que voltar pra casa e 56 dias
depois pôde recomeçar mas
psicologicamente também foi complicado
porque eu saí da minha rotina
deixei amigos família namorada trabalho
em busca desse sonho
sempre me perguntam se eu tive medo ou
pensei em desistir pelo caminho sim
quase diariamente na onu os dias mais
difíceis a gente pensa em desistir mas
quando você está isolado num uma região
selvagem sozinho desistiram tira dali
não resolve os seus problemas
como num passe de mágica então quando o
dia ruim termina o novo dia começa e os
motivos e os problemas do dia anterior
os motivos para desistir já não existem
mais
você segue
amparado aqui no sul da patagônia
argentina à meia-noite 50 começou uma
forte tempestade
temperar a pior tempestade que eu já vi
na minha vida eu me lembro que parecia
que havia uma multidão de pessoas
golpeando a barraca assim por fora eu
passei a noite em claro
segurando a barraca por dentro tive que
colocar parte da minha bagagem em cima
de mim
para evitar que o voasse com a barraca
porque quando montei acampamento não
havia vento e eu não aprendi não fixei a
barraca corretamente ao chão foi um
estresse tão intenso que tive dores de
estômago e acordei de manhã com um pouco
de lama no rosto assim a na amazônia
peruana depois de ter passado por um
pequeno povoado eu não conseguir um
lugar adequado para acampar
não me senti totalmente seguro então me
afastei do povoado alguns quilômetros já
no escuro absoluto seria minha a minha
segurança garantida e se ninguém me
visse acampando ali estaria seguro
a campeã ao lado da campeã ao lado da
selva e a no meio da madrugada um animal
se aproximou da barraca
eu podia ouvir os passos ea e ouvir a
respiração não sei que o animal é mas eu
me lembro bem do medo e ter passado a
madrugada acordado com os olhos
arregalados no escuro absoluto com o
canivete a mão como se aquilo fosse me
salvar de alguma forma eu tive 11
companheiros
esse ano de viagem 11 ciclistas que
estavam viajando também alguns fazendo
viagens mais curtas outras viagens mais
longas que a minha
desses 11 o perdão desses 11 eu posso
citar os mais importantes
o francês vincent ficou 45 dias comigo
pela pampa argentina lutando diariamente
contra o vento
a gente tava indo para o sul evento
vinha do sul então foram dois mil
quilômetros com vento contra
e também posso falar do ralf um alemão
que passou há 54 dias comigo foram 54
dias viajando juntos
convivendo 24 horas por dia está
acompanhado é muito bom porque te dá
alguma segurança para acampar em lugares
que você não a campanha sozinho né
companhia nos momentos difíceis nas
alegrias mas não é sempre um mar de
rosas com ele por exemplo a nós éramos
pessoas muito diferentes em alguns
aspectos e nós brigávamos às vezes
discutir discutíamos por momento por por
motivos bobos
chegamos a viajar dois ou três dias sem
falar juntos assim eu me lembro dele
voltando a falar comigo num acampamento
da barraca dele me pedindo para colocar
uma música pink floyd
então a gente tinha essa no final o
saldo foi positivo para a gente assim é
um grande amigo uma pessoa que eu
respeito muito a solidão sempre foi uma
faca de dois gumes para mim ao mesmo
tempo que os dias difíceis ela acaba
sendo mais um ponto para ser superado
nos momentos de alegria era um deleite
para mim e cruzar regiões isoladas do
continente sozinho fazia parte do plano
e eu vivi aquele intensamente
foi um momento de descoberta e
autoconhecimento para mim nesse dia o
dia 254 para ser mais exato
eu havia pedalado 50 71 quilômetros e
como acontecia nos dias no deserto do
atacama não havia uma chegada algum
lugar simplesmente ap o deserto então
teria que acampar escolher se esse ponto
pra para montar o acampamento e me
afastei uns 300 metros da estrada para
buscar mais mais tranquilidade apesar do
tráfego a lista é muito muito pequeno eu
queria um pouco mais de distância da
estrada
então comecei a olhar o horizonte ali
antes de montar a barraca e não havia
sido
da presença humana onde olhasse só
pedras areia
o céu azul então eu fui longe entrei num
transe assim é como era o auge do que eu
havia sonhado pra mim naquele momento
então a brisa veio me despertou e disse
que era hora de montar acampamento
o sol já estava se pondo eu corri pra à
beira da estrada para buscar pedras para
colocar sobre as alças da barraca para
evitar que ela voasse com o vento forte
porque o solo é muito duro e eu não
conseguia colocar as estacas para fixar
lá no chão e dormir no meio da madrugada
eu despertei e então eu abriu o zíper da
barraca e vi isso a via láctea cortando
o céu
de um lado a outro não havia sinal de
luzes das cidades a na linha do
horizonte estava a 200 km da cidade mais
próxima e tudo o que havia vivido até
ali passou rapidamente com um filme
assim a minha cabeça e óbvia conseguido
meu meu objetivo é realizado estava
aliás no meio do meu sonho já não
conseguia mais separar a fantasia da
realidade por um segundo aquelas
palavras como nirvana ou iluminação
fizeram sentido pra mim
pela manhã eu tenho uma olhada no meu
estoque de água tinha mais meio litro de
água e seria um dia difícil porque não
existem fontes naturais de água em pelo
menos 1.500 quilômetros
e aí eu vi os primeiros raios de sol
refletindo no veículo que vinha um
quilômetro a quilômetro e meio de
distância sair correndo descalço acabar
com a garrafa vazia na mão foi até a
beira da rodovia mostrou a garrafa vazia
um caminhão parou
é uma lei não escrita do deserto de
distribuir água e ele me deu três litros
de água duas garrafas geladas e uma maçã
essa experiência também me fez confiar
nas pessoas
confiar em estranhos mesmo que eu
gostasse de resolver as coisas sozinho
eventualmente você vai ter que confiar
em alguém tem uma história aqui
aliás aqui perto no extremo sul do
estado do rio grande do sul que ilustra
bem isso eu havia passado a noite num
pasto em uma região rural a noite não
tinha sido muito boa não o chão era
irregular e não foi muito confortável
café da manhã também foi fraco não foi
muito bom não tem a bagagem a bicicleta
para se começar mais um dia e depois de
pedalar a apenas 100 quilômetros
perdão 100 metros passando à frente da
casa de um homem em uma casinha simples
de madeira ele me convidou
ele queria que eu ficasse na casa dele
seu nome é antônio
ele insistiu apesar de estar começando
meu dia ele insistiu e eu aceitei o
convite
passei o dia com ele o homem simples me
contou uma infinidade de histórias e
mostrou seus animais disse que havia uma
cama disponível estava cheio de
excrementos de cupim mas estava
disponível foi onde eu passei a minha
noite pois me banhar então uma forte
chuva começou
eu me sentia fortunado de ter-se
aceitado o convite
é ele fez uma janta para a gente ele
cozinhou ele não tinha hábito de jantar
e fez questão de cozinhar para mim então
o fatos como esse se mudaram para sempre
a minha forma de ver as pessoas quantas
pessoas fariam isso eu faria isso será
que eu faria isso por um estranho
passando à frente da minha casa
então como sair ilesa de uma experiência
como essa isso aconteceu inúmeras vezes
dezenas talvez uma centena de vezes
durante o ano de viagem com um ano de
viagem eu eu me sentia realmente
invencível e forte assim sabe eu sentia
que podia dar a volta ao mundo se
quisesse
aos poucos eu tô ingerindo ainda que eu
vivi naquele ano
leva tempo e eu eu buscava a felicidade
certa forma acho que é uma busca
constante de todos
encontrei só que também descobri que ela
é efêmera a mesmo sendo temporária ela
está ao alcance de todos e não é um bem
que você pode adquirir comprar acumular
não é um produto e aquele aquele menino
que eu procurava eu encontrei aquele mim
eu encontrei aquele menino com medo do
desconhecido coração disparado em
algumas situações
encontrei aquele menino no céu estrelado
do deserto
encontrei aquele menino na alegria de se
estar onde sonhou estar um dia e também
vi aquele olhar das crianças que
encontra pelo caminho o olhar de
curiosidade e deslumbramento pelo mundo
que nos cerca e hoje eu vejo esse mesmo
olhar na minha filha que é uma pessoa
que só existe hoje porque um dia eu
resolvi realizar o meu sonho
a gente tem que tomar cuidado a gente
não pode deixar que o menino e
n aqui nós carregamos dentro de nós se
perca pelo caminho
já nascemos com esse olhar de
curiosidade deslumbramento sobre o mundo
essa é a mensagem que eu queria passar
hoje pra vocês aqui muito obrigado